[Musique]
mais info ou intox avec antoine penot ce
soir antoine bonsoir au menu la guerre
en ukraine avec le massacre de boudhha
drame qui déchaîne les un fax oui
absolument clé la découverte
souvenez-vous en de centaines de corps
dans cette ville de la région de kiev
qui a nourri il faut bien dire les infos
que de tout genre j'en ai choisi
quelques unes pour vous pêle-mêle la
première autour de cette vidéo vous
apercevez en ce moment à l'image les
images en elles mêmes sont assez
difficiles je ne vais donc pas vous les
montrer on y voit des soldats ukrainien
déplacer des corps à l'aide de câbles
qui l'ont fixé sur ses cordes de quoi
interroger cet internaute vous le voyez
au dessus sur ce twitt pourquoi et
sautent des ukrainiens repositionne t-il
donc les corps comme ça sous-entendus et
bien c'est une mise en scène vous l'avez
compris l'explication pourtant elle est
assez simple à trouver comme souvent il
suffit de faire une petite recherche
d'image inversée et on retrouve
l'origine de cette vidéo vous le voyez
ici elle est issue de l' agence
américaine de presse et hippies des
images qui ont bien été tournées abuja
nous rappelle l' agence on y trouve
aussi vous allez comprendre
l'explication de ces corps traîné par
des caps est assez sordide c'est
malheureusement le drame de la guerre
vous allez le comprendre et bien le fpi
nous explique dans ce court texte est
bien que les ukrainiens craignent que
ces corps soient piégés par des
explosifs dont qu'il l'était place à
l'aide de ces câbles pour éviter des
mauvaises surprises donc vous l'aurez
compris ça c'était pour le premier
exemple d'un fox clair une à fox donc
basés sur à la fois un manque
d'information il faut bien dire et
surtout une interprétation douteuse
notre un phoque cette fois elle c'est
celle de la vidéo sorti de son contexte
vous l'apercevez ici cet internaute lui
partagent cette séquence d'un mannequin
manipuler un poreuse qui semblent être
deux hommes en treillis le tweet
l'accompagnant lui est ouvertement
complotistes après les faux mort du co
vie de 19 fois ci les faux morts de la
guerre une séquence visionner quand même
près de trente mille fois même très
30000 froid très exactement sur son
compte twitter là encore c'est assez
facile de retrouver l'origine de la
vidéo on voit avoué le petit logo tik
tok qui a pas à cette vidéo avec le nom
du compte et bien c'est assez facile de
retrouver ce qu'on tictoc le voici c'est
celui de cet homme c'est un comédien
russe il s'appelle philippe fédéraux
tchouk et on voit bien ici en vous voyez
cette vidéo ici et qui est cette vidéo
qui est donc posté sur son compte il
tant qu est la légende qu'il met ici que
j'ai traduit pour vous et on ne peut
plus clair il dit préparez un mannequin
pour une chute de cinéma voilà c'est
clair philippe dayraut de shoot qui est
possède également aussi un compte
instagram où on l'aperçoit et bien
qu'ils participent régulièrement des
tournages de ce genre c'était notamment
le cas on le voit ici sur ces derniers
jours elle était à saint pétersbourg
pour un film baptisé accrochez vous
admire eyes of district 2 la fiche
technique du film je les retrouver sur
un site
spécialisé russe de l'actualité du
cinéma vous l'apercevez ici une vidéo
donc là on retrouve le mécanisme
classique d un fox clairement vidéo
décontextualisés est rattachée donc un
événement récent et ça ne s'arrête pas
là la théorie de la mise en scène de ce
massacre à bout de chat est largement
relayée par les pro-russes oui c'est
peut-être ça le plus inquiétant
finalement notamment autour d'une faute
au tir et vous le voyez de d'un compte
instagram est partagé par ce conte
ouvertement pro russe il affirme que
cette jeune femme que l'on voit ici que
je vous montrerai un petit peu plus tard
s'est fait prendre en photo en mimant
être morte il affirme que c'est une info
fox qu'elle a essayé par la suite de
justifier on a retrouvé nos infos intox
le compte instagram de cette ukrainienne
le voici et on retrouvait la post
effectivement cette photo c'était le 4
avril sur son compte mais ce que le
tweet ne dit pas en revanche c'est qu
elle n'affirme pas avoir été tués par
l'armée russe à bout de chats elle dit
ça aurait pu être moi un message de
sensibilisation donc il faut il faut le
comprendre comme ça et pas du tout une
volonté de diffuser une fausse
information en faveur de qui que ce soit
ses mises en scène pour interpeller sur
les massacres des civils ayant les
retrouve sur d'autres comptes
d'ukrainiens j'en ai choisi quelques-uns
pour vous voyez ici avec cette jeune
femme qui pose également dans la même
situation est également sur cet autre
cet autre utilisatrice de twitter qui
elle aussi relayent un peu le même
message donc vous voyez on a bien
campagne de sensibilisation sur ces
massacres et pas du tout vous l'aurez
compris une soi-disant mise en scène de
quoi que ce soit merci beaucoup antoine
feno c'était info ou intox on peut
retrouver votre chronique sur notre site
internet bien sûr
www.francebillet.com